we have a voicemail number which is two
one nine two david p here's a really
good it really comes down to an issue of
math take a listen to this question
hi David I was wondering if Trump loses
the popular vote let's say by a
landslide or buy it like a large amount
yes still possible for him to win the
electoral vote and when the election and
if you could explain that thank you yeah
so listen there's there's two answers to
this right if you imagine that all 50
state elections are completely
independent of each other right that
there is no there they are uncorrelated
then yeah there are actually models
which show that you can get only 27% of
the popular vote and become president
and win the electoral college so that's
never happened that's an extreme example
I believe that the biggest popular vote
loss where they still won the electoral
college was 2016 Trump lost by more than
two points to Hillary Clinton in the
popular vote and still won because of
three states where his total margin was
about seventy-five thousand votes George
W Bush in 2000 lost the popular vote by
a tiny bit and won the electoral college
so the the mathematical answer is you
could win the electoral college with
only 27 percent of the popular vote it's
never happened I imagine that if Trump
loses the popular vote by more than
three three or more he will lose the
electoral college because remember it
was like 2.2 that he lost to Hillary by
and he he just barely squeaked it out if
the margin in the popular vote is three
or three and a half the odds of Trump
losing the popular vote by that much and
still winning the electoral college
would be I don't want to put a number to
it a statistician could do it but it's
got to be won in a very very big big
number I would actually be interested to
see data what are the odds of winning
electoral II if you lose by three what
are the odds of willing when a winning
electoral II if you lose by four and the
reason why it's so unlikely
is that elections are not uncorrelated
right if Donald Trump loses Florida by a
big margin it is very unlikely that he's
also not losing other important states
by a sizable margin which would make it
extremely unlikely that you would have
you know like a seven-point loss in the
popular vote and still somehow win
electoral II doesn't mean it's
impossible it's just never happened and
I don't expect it to I believe that the
sort of limit would probably be
spitballing here three or three and a
half that if Trump loses popular by
three and a half he's gonna lose
electoral II if there is data on this I
haven't looked for it I would love to
see it like maybe we would find out that
oh you know if you lose by two you still
have a 25% of winning the the electoral
college if you lose by three it goes
down to only two percent and if you lose
by four it's only like one and a
thousand or something like that there's
probably some curve which mathematicians
have figured out I would love to see it
send it to me if you're aware of it on
the bonus show today we will talk about
a situation in which election night in
November could really be election week
or even election month some of you
probably have an idea of how that could
be we're also going to talk about more
statue related drama this this is here
in Boston that it's happening and lastly
in the context of discussions about
police protocol we are going to talk
about no-knock warrants we've talked
about no-knock warrants before but I
want to devote a little more time to it
so get a membership to get access to the
bonus show at join pakman.com quick easy
and cheap remember that if you prefer a
long-form audio podcast to youtube clips
you can get our free podcast on itunes
stitcher
Spotify Pandora Google Play podcast
wherever you like to listen to your
podcasts and number three tomorrow night
join the chess tournament 8:00 p.m.
Eastern Tuesday June 16th david
pakman.com slash chess to sign up free
open to everyone and i hope to see you
there